okay all right for people joining this
live stream we are looking at new
features in know somebody needs to mute
themselves there we are looking at new
features in graphs another theory okay
interesting combination for 12.1 see
roughly how what we have to do here all
right let's start off by the way I have
been using the graph theory stuff as
Charles knows and it's basically working
really quite well so that's good hey
Charles can tell me one thing
have you been using their new to try one
stuff yes yes good will come what's up
how come I've been doing all kinds of
cool things trying to figure out the
universe you know there well there is
that I'll show you an example of
something just for just to UM just to
provide context of some coin let me see
what I can find something here about the
bar
let's see that's a growing hypergraph
and that's so I wrote some code for
making hypergraphs this is an ordered
hyper graph um
it's kind of pulls out combinations of
vertices and polygons Liza's them like
this
a one thing by the way I need to know
Charles is the graph embedding function
um what is the how do I get the 3d
embedding only I know that I figured
that out sorry it's just the second
argument of graph embedding yes but I
mean I've also been doing stuff with
them all kinds of tagging and so on so
it's it's some I'm so far so good I
think we completely looked at the tag
graph stuff last time remind me what tag
graph is again remind me what it is
yeah yeah we changed it last time edge
tagged graph yeah right right right
right exactly right actually we should
probably using this for some of the
things we're doing um directed edge with
tag okay directed edge new can I look at
it here the new stuff should never build
I mean there yeah okay fine so what it
what do you what are you showing it okay
this is represented to directed edge
with that tag that's wonderful yeah
actually I need to make sure that Maxime
who's working on the some graph the
hyper graph stuff knows about this could
is there any p.m. person here nope okay
it's just us all right then I am going
to screen capture that and do something
very primitive here um
okay all right
annotations have we looked at this we
did not but this is the design that we
agreed on with you know when we have
several big meetings yeah I remember
that and do you think it's working okay
yeah okay
I think that there is still more
experience to be gotten as we add
annotations to more kinds of objects
but that's that's something that we will
have to learn as we grow you know grow
into other very well what were you
saying that by the way as we add support
for annotations to other objects I think
that there is more things to learn but
we kind of have to learn that as we do
those growing into those domains yeah
you
you
you
you
oh that's an interesting point from
Sandra our livestream a lot of code uses
first and last on directed edge to get
the beginning and end points of an edge
ouch well shouldn't between that I mean
that's not the same what is the
recommended way what is the recommended
way of getting the start point to the
end point of an edge no I'm sorry
in a directed edge I have a directed
edge okay how do I get the beginning of
the directed edge so is UV so you take
the first on the second one
no no somebody will take look whether
it's the first and second or first and
last
they're both Hackett I mean that's both
a bit they're both a bit hacky right or
a sub value for directed edge possibly
does that make any sense are we doing
that for graphs at this point no
what would we call it I mean it would be
nicer to look in the cut piece of code
that says you know has a fold list of
you know folding across some across
edges to see the thing say you know
beginning of our gender age or whatever
it is um what would be how would we do
that by the way this particular point
about directed edge of last of directed
edge we should absolutely tell people to
look for that because it will indeed
break code right so what is our
mechanism for getting people to do that
maybe some value maybe a function to do
that to return the vertex that's not
what I'm saying to you what I'm saying
to you is how do we communicate to users
this change might break your code do you
understand what I'm saying yes okay I
think that's a separate thing let's talk
about in the roadmap meeting next the
next roadmap meeting
ok I think we actually have one coming
up right after this so let's talk about
that there okay okay can you bring that
or do I have to send a note to get that
to happen I have to send a note to get
that there happen we really need a
project manager in these meetings this
doesn't make sense
you
okay what are we going to do about this
the both thumb I mean it will not affect
unless you use tagged edges if you if
you use a normal graph directed
undirected weighted everything is as
normal
tags are only for multi graphs that's a
good point that is a good point that is
a good point that's that's the point to
make okay three argument form another
comment from the livestream three
argument for undirected edge no longer
canonicalize undirected edges using sort
what the point is if you have an
undirected edge how do you canonicalize
the undirected edge in other words if
you say undirected edge of it's a
question of where are two undirected
edges are equal yes
that's why you want that normally there
should be other less but we don't really
want to order less of the system because
he wins by default so the arguments and
now it certainly can't be less to do as
well as there's always also several of
those issue that the pattern match
should not directly map them because
doesn't know that the order like
something don't coincide so this is a
problem I mean okay how do we I mean it
will be annoying to have to provide
something called sort edges right what's
the right way to do this the key point
is first the workflow why do you want to
sort edges right I mean there is several
other way to do that
you know sorting is non assessed with
the right way well what is the right way
is depending on the goal or what the
person wants to achieve
so say they've got a bunch of undirected
edges that were produced somehow and
they want to you know merge them let's
say serum say
merged of the crass if you build the
graph all that will be done first of all
right well and one crucial thing
specially for you know edge directed
edge on the right edge is that we try to
preserve the order you give it as you
construct it that way but when you do
edge list we don't even sort them and
when you generate them form for example
fan cycle right we try to keep that you
know that sequence of edges so that you
have you know visually if you take first
of them you have a pattern so there's
that whole consistency we preserve which
are quite useful what does that mean
what I just got there so in that cycle
you have B to ay ay to B but if I if I
done the graph ABA B I would still have
okay so I do that and now I say fine
cycle of that but because we want to
return two parts well that's interesting
because those are uncanonical eyes
that's a good argument for not sorting
the undirected edge right thinking that
I mean we in our long term plan we have
this tag which was also coming so if I
put a tag here why is it turning red oh
well the Fontan you have to update all
these legit wait okay
so if I say show that graph with vertex
labels true how do I get it to also show
the tags me mean edge I see so if I say
edge labels arrow automat UPS oops oops
oops you need to put automatic in there
right yes No
what happened there
- good - is something look look at the
labels the labels are bonkers see those
labels this is a tagged edge right child
yes why isn't it I want the tag as the
label on the edge Oh what we haven't
introduced a name that that automatic
kiss behave the same has the vertex
label automatic mean the names actual
objects okay but okay how do I put the
tags as the labels we haven't yet I
think automatic should put the tags as
the labels if it has tags on if she
doesn't have tags I mean I don't think
it should
don't think it should put I don't think
should ever do this I think this is
really weird I mean you could maybe say
all or something to do this if you want
to this is weird if it has tags use the
tags I mean when you deal with non tag
edge in that for central cough you know
all just making that you know make sense
you know edge label automatic you want
to look at you know what corresponding
edge on doing stuff but we know we
shouldn't forget that side to whatever
you want to do what I say usually when
you know you generate a graph which is
sample it sample graph you don't have
multiple edges or tags but I want to do
an edge label you just want to see the
name of the edge right automatic make
sense and we never had that issue what
sorry what do you do when you have the
network what is the name of the edge if
it isn't the tag name is if you do
complete have five edge goes to
automatic right sometime you know you
want to manipulate and just look at the
edges so
although if you want to set annotations
and other things the name of the edge is
just that you know a undirected edge a B
that is 10 full mega it's interesting
that doesn't look bad actually that
looks better than I might have thought
okay but but if there is a tag surely
automatic should just put the tag there
but I would do all or something or true
edge labels to true should do this see
what I'm saying but singing compatible
changed and why what does true do right
now no I'm just saying that this is what
automatic has been doing what what
you're just seeing oops but not for
tagged edges because we haven't had
tagged edges for Ain
well in principle actually we had that
edge since the first release
we just haven't document them activate
them because there's that whole thing we
needed to build and make sure the fact
that the thing of turning red means and
we can ask people are a live stream
whether they've ever used tagged edges
but no no no what we said no that's not
what he said and it's not what we meant
so what are you saying about so I think
we should make edge labels to automatic
show the tags if there are tags okay if
there aren't tags you've got to do this
whole thing here I would do edge labels
either to true or to all doing this
behavior here right okay question you
know I just did am see
okay now it was claimed that this
doesn't work if I publish this to the
cloud
you
have you have you checked this for the
clouds well we did that I don't know
session a long time ago long time ago
no so this is not alive oh yeah it is
okay just during rotation it doesn't
show so that works so somebody on the
livestream is complaining this doesn't
work but I think it does work it's just
the preview image and that's an issue
that John I just asked John Pacey to
look at is the way preview images work
for complex graphics and 3d but that's
mr. working fine um I think that that
WebGL implementation is quite limited to
dos there live stuff I understand but he
should just put insert choose you should
put lines there that's just a gut a
glitch okay question for the live stream
about first search and complaining that
they were horrible functions to use okay
I don't have an opinion about them I
mean this is the full generality the
problem is that what you often need is
something simpler you don't rarely do we
need this level of generality so let me
ask a question so so one of the things
coming up from what I'm doing I'm doing
graph rewrites the question is what's
the updating order in a graph rewrite
does this provide me no this does not
because this is pure depth-first scan is
that right what does that even mean
that's exactly what it means but I mean
does that mean that there's only one
updating order that I get here that that
means there's only one visiting order
that I get yeah that we have the ability
that you can actually slightly change
control the visiting order at some point
I mean the fact is this idea of look
around as you're visiting we don't even
have it for map
I'm saying hmm right so what is the
analog of map for doing something to a
graph
I won't take the graph and I want to
look at every neighborhood in the graph
and I want to do something to every
neighborhood in the graph which to me is
would be an obvious kind of thing to do
I want to look at every go ahead then
it's a state change between them it's
not so map is completely parallel
there's no state change happening
absolutely so what I'm saying is imagine
I have a graph and I want to visit every
node inspect its local neighborhood and
decide what to do and build a new
structure based I mean so what map would
do is it would essentially insert
something into it puts a function I mean
so I don't know exactly how that works
here because what see what what's odd
about this as compared to map is map
descends the tree and locally looks at a
subtree and all it knows is the subtree
it's looking at right now for a graph
all nodes are equal in some sense so
there is no obvious sub tree you're
looking at and it's not the case that
you can just take a function and apply
it to some sub graph and expect things
to you know glue together correctly did
that make sense yes so I don't know what
is a typical application here of this
depth first scan I mean these are all
side effects which are showing here it's
a scam function so everything you do is
going to be scientific a so my question
is is there a map function that goes
along with this
no should there be
I don't possible if is useful so far
vignette but I mean if everybody if what
everybody is doing is a repin or so on
this
yeah I mean it will be interesting to
see some cases of this you know this
okay
what's the analog of you know you
collect data from every local
neighborhood see then I'm confused by
let's imagine that you have a function
which is given the graph centered on a
particular node
yeah it's just very unclear what this
should do I we would okay so responding
to ether Maya livestream um the
statement there were horrible functions
to use tell us tell us something you
would like to do with them because other
than sort of exercises I'm not sure I'm
not sure what what people you know you
tell me I mean what what you know the
fact that they're Sophia I mean this
function is kind of a joke because look
at how long its description is and look
at how few examples it has right that
kind of tells you something right there
I mean the strange because normally it
have more than that something if
something is because one application
first something is missing in that first
we have great firsts like to compute
connectivity I mean I receive 50% of
cough algorithmic reversals white on it
essentially that so we provide that
depth first Center fees to user if you
want to so if you want to build your own
version of connected cough you you can
just use the first one by the way I
assume you're gonna edit all these
property value things right yes well
this looks like it has lots of juicy
stuff I don't understand the packaging
of these functions it seems like a very
interesting exercise to try and
understand this better but I haven't I
don't know what the patterns I mean
looking at these examples can you see
any pattern that you could package
differently yeah there's some basic
cases where you know usually people want
you know explicitly do the list of
vertex visited vertices on such where we
can provide those function instead of
having complex callback function on this
is just essentially two general but it
cover all the possible cases well maybe
what you want to suggest something given
that this is just doing a scan right
it's it is basically generating an
ordering of the graph right
yes if you look at the vertices yes
okay so in a sense one way to do it
would be to just say you know one thing
that seems useful is just a thing that
says you know Brett first um vertex list
that would be a useful function and I
would recommend it which is the return
value of this function but I've got to
give all this other crud as well well if
you I think if you don't give anything
you actually just get it by default okay
so if I say like this okay well if I
might say so where the heck is that how
about putting that as the very very
first usage thing there and then the
very very first example before you get
to any of these other weird things with
pre visits and so on makes sense by the
way you should blow use echo there but
whatever um I
seems useful to me
because then I can just go in and do
whatever I want and you know find
whatever I don't understand quite what
this is otherwise doing for me but I
couldn't do given that list gender Stan
might my point yes but I mean if one you
want to implement an type of Al Gore you
know you need to actually know the state
of the father so if you for example want
to check that the graph is connected if
you do a depth first and then you find
out you know a set a stage or you want
to detect cycle but you can easily exit
by knowing that you you know you can
contact Isis okay those states which are
quite useful okay can I ask you can you
confirm you're gonna put as the very
first thing here Brett the first scan of
G returns the list of vertices in a
breadth-first order but yes scan order
okay that will help a lot I'll help
something and I would like to I think
really interesting to look at that some
more okay um
look it's
he finished commenting on we should be
able to tag vertices as well as edges no
that's not I mean you can do whatever
you wanted a vertex you can call the
vertex anything you want you can have
all kinds of data in the quotes name of
the vertex right either in the name or
as an annotation it's really more
sensible less an annotation right okay
all right let's keep going here I would
really like to I'm sorry I feel that we
could be making a mistake here I would
really like to see some examples with
these things just to make sure we're not
goofing something up did you have them
do we have some real examples here yet
um well we try to put some basic example
if you open I think if you use the tool
okay I'm gonna try to use these I'm
concerned because I feel
you
what does that mean annotation names are
just a generic graph what does that mean
so if I say this
okay and then I say annotation names
okay what does that mean what the hell
is that those are named annotations and
those happen to be standard
standard annotations also known as
options but those are treated as
annotations that US standard ly
supported
okay so if I want to annotate
customized of the standard once I
understand okay so let's say I want to
annotate I want to turn red let me do a
random graph here okay
okay now I want to turn red all vertices
with numbers below 10 how do I do that
vertex style
um I
I I slashed
or you could set
you can use the value and just set it
okay how do I do that so you can do our
notation value connotation value of
yeah that's rough
let's call this graph GG okay annotation
value of GG yep well it just sees you
know in the least G coma one just use it
so Akuma they textile okay why didn't
that have a carrot if it needs two
arguments
that's about well there's a general case
about okay what's next here they textile
okay now I can say equals red is that
right yes okay now if I say
Gigi again god that's weird okay and so
what this allows you to do is actually
real time algorithm anime animation
among other things
if you want to if you want to show
something traversing a graph or building
up a graph in real time yes nice
that can mean of course we don't have
the can't don't have four graphics but
we do have it for graphs
yeah okay but the thing we don't have
for for graphics is we don't have a
scene graph we don't have their dress
ability no I understand is this nice and
fast yeah but you need I think you wanna
to have it turned to work fine yeah
if you do a little if you do a little
pause there you would see them change
I'm saying - it's going to be too fast
now but if you want to be able
follow it at human speed see I
understand and pausing like when two
seconds there's hope I say and here do
that but then I want to say dynamic of
Gigi
exactly
I lost point two or something
well I can't see a damn thing happening
if anything's happening I can't see it
um how do I do if I say vertex style but
excise but what is the units of that so
if I say three will they be big
that's very cool that was very cool very
nice and that becomes quite powerful
when you want to see traversals
following something or build up if you
search you see how a frontier of edges
evolve for instance yeah I like the lot
um even a live stream is saying that
annotations versus tags should be made
clearer what is the difference between
annotation and tag so if I want to put
in here if I say annotation of GG comma
5 comma fishiness
you mean annotate white or annotation of
value a fishiness equals false right and
now I want to say annotation now I can
retrieve annotation value of gg5 that
right yeah but do you say now which now
which which annotation so so that's
gonna be a matter is there at all there
should be with an association returning
an association cool
so syntax coloring and an all fruit with
an association makes sense yes I'd like
to play with us some more so what does
annotate to do is annotate the same
thing as saying annotation value equals
what's the difference no it doesn't do
that it's it's like a wrapper it's it's
oh oh oh right okay what's the
difference in annotation value equals
and annotate or is annotate the same as
annotation value equals two vertically
they're the same but in and within value
it L value is more efficient since you
have this symbol or changing it in place
in some cases but I see I see so this
case so if I were to say here if I were
to say annotate Gigi well this is kind
of weird name our oh I see eletric Gigi
five and then I say vertex size arrow
five for example right and I get the
graph back but Gigi is unchanged it's
nice
ok makes sense is that explained
properly somewhere I think we should
have something in the guide page which
should make sure that we explain this
and we make sure that we explain the
validation value can be an L value in
the guide page well both but I mean I
think but I mean we should show
annotation value is an an early example
with annotation value is in L value
right
okay graph constructors
so expression graph what is this this is
like
so how does this relate to the trees
business this is compatible with the
trees business because we're gonna have
a separate expression tree thing how did
you know how Toni's project on trees is
going well I talked to Jose office told
me that since last time there was pretty
much no progress on twitter' law I think
Tony's coming back on such a thing I'm
told what how they told me essentially I
think the last meeting you have last
year nothing have been done here what
are you talking about
okay Tony is now actively supposed to be
working on that project are you telling
me that your recent information is that
that's not happening okay then I have to
go chase it let me send mail if my
information is accurate I hope
doesn't because I was told that it was
actively being worked on since we don't
have a project manager here nobody can
go check okay
you
so what is this so
this is to support the font eating off
so this
why isn't oh I see the entity oh that's
nice that's really nice so if I say
graph of um control equals I don't know
butterfly graph is there a butterfly
graph cool
I see so if I were to say for example
here vertex list is probably sent well
let's try
I see so there's a bunch of things in
here
well let me point out that this is not a
useful page right you should be saying
something you should be using graph here
right application well okay so it should
be in basic examples that you can see
something other than just how to get to
you know what I'm saying right should
have something in basically since you
know basic applications isn't isn't open
by default you should put something
above the fold okay so I don't quite
that what the heck what the heck is that
a failure in quantity something yeah I
understand that but why is this resource
data is not the graph why did you choose
to make the default element not the
graph itself no if that's the Somali
which is a second argument oh oh oh oh
so that is the graph itself okay now
what are we doing with with showing
being able to make summaries of very big
graphs visual summaries are very big
graphs hmm I think the closest we have
is what you're looking at now that's a
summary blurb and you can you can open a
plus sign you get more summary
statistics no no no no I'm talking about
a visual summary of the structure of
this graph like zoomed out like if I
wasn't going to actually render the
whole thing like in the case of this
particular graph you know I'm sure if I
actually render it can I do that by just
saying graph of that No
Bobby got not supposed to try to do that
if I take this I'll get some big messy
thing right okay so my question is what
we want to do like you know if you use
an interactive graph viewer and you are
zooming out a long way right it's not
showing you every node you know what I'm
saying yes so what is our idea for how
to down sample this is there some
obvious algorithmic way to down sample
the graph and then get you know
essentially a summary like this what
would you what would happen in an
attractive graph viewer if we were
looking at this we would get some kind
of summary of this right but just how
does the summary work well I think most
of the time is a matter of structure you
want to show I'm not sure that there are
such some reason you know because
normally you zoomed in and then you have
an overview which is a navigation window
in one or the corners that allows okay
how where's the old are you coming from
I mean in other words are you rendering
look at some point does one compute
every piece of the graph or not is the
question so it could be if you look at
this there's a certain rendering time
and there's a certain computation time
how does that break down do you mean for
this specific case if they grow a big
graph how does it break down go ahead if
you put a semi-coma to the cuff plot
actually generate a fix
yes so in thermo ah that's faster should
be fast okay so if I say percent forty
one if I say um absolute time
okay it's the same graph
sixteen thousand nodes 121,000 edges 20
seconds much longer to do well normally
should be actually below that should be
in less than a second but in principle
like spring electrical also should be
pretty fast on those okay when we plan
to honor it we first then there could be
a version of graph plot which has some
kind of coarse graining down sampling
which doesn't then render every node it
knows essentially the density of nodes
on the screen because like rendering
every node in here is a waste of time
right yes yes so how could we do that we
did spend some time thinking about that
early on but it's it's I don't think we
have a viable such you know plan or
model at this point but yes it has come
up and we have spent some time thinking
especially like the case of the high
dimensional embedding which is
essentially this thing illogical in high
dimension
so essentially you do still save a layer
so at one layer you can actually show
this off the view of the graph well I
sort of a think that look with all these
things I think it it not only needs sort
of an idea but also experimentation
because visuals without checking it I
mean you could imagine if something is
is is strongly connected or something
like that it gets rendered as a as a
node as a blob sure cuz there's nothing
to say everything is connected you don't
really need to know that
until you decide to drill down yes sort
of you can use like what you have
community graph plot right yeah sure
that is still showing every every node
and you don't need to do that yes I say
we can't use the same skin but then just
instead of saying those node we just
show one I think there would be a good
idea can we can we look at that I mean
in in um okay but I think there's I mean
I kind of think that there's more than
one idea here of you know so a
visualization like that it depends what
you want to so this so this person
Maxime is going to be working on a bunch
of these graphs for the physics project
um he would be a good person he's a good
software engineer he would be a good
person to to look at some of these
things so Charles you should make sure
he's coming to the conference you should
make sure to talk to him about this
stuff okay and maybe he can try and
prototype some of these things because I
think he's gonna need them anyway
sure question from Ethan can we get d3
styling primitives for sexier graph plot
themes I do not know what's there but
that seems like the kind of thing we
should be able to do do we have a plot
theme thing for graph we do yes so but
they're not considered sexy
sexy but but but it never hurts to look
at what's there I don't I don't correct
you know what d3 has
perhaps Tim or somebody should look at
it that looks kind of cool that is cool
yeah um please make graphs compilation
friendly what does that mean
ya know while doing operations on graphs
being able to but that's I think a
question of um I'm not sure okay
ah sander says vertex list of undirected
edge could return the list that is a
good idea
here's the idea simple idea but that's a
good idea why not have that
returnless de Bie seems like a good idea
do you agree yeah yeah I guess he could
also don't work on a list of those yes
that's a good idea too
so Charles Thank You Santa that was a
good idea and Charles can we implement
that shorts okay and document it I mean
seems like an obvious way to do this and
then first and last would work on the
vertex list of an undirected edge which
makes sense um Ethan is complaining that
when you have a lot of large graphs and
a notebook frame rates grind to a halt
why is that as there's anything dynamic
in these graphs and in a graph here is
that dynamic in some way so
would why would the front-end grind to a
halt if it's a big graph like that with
millions sure well it's not sure because
the front-end is maintaining it cash
anyway a bitmap cache of what's coming
on that page um
it's worth looking at I don't know why
but every we looked at that to make sure
if you have a notebook of many small
graphs it should be fast I think that's
something that I recall us specifically
yes I mean listen listen I've got some
notebooks with lots of graphs in them
and they do fine
so I'm not quite sure what we're talking
about here classics okay fair enough
um the complaint is that graphs on the
Loudon function compile to compile an
Auror Association yeah many more types
will be rolling out there down sample
working on graphs I don't see how that
would work
sorry what down sample working on graphs
I don't see how that would work
because I don't know what you a down
sample really only works for adjacent
things you know you take one out of five
but I don't know what that would do
I'm asked beause you could make it work
you could decimate the graph but I think
that would just produce completely
different results wouldn't it just maybe
sub half of the sampling of theta C so
edges edge list of it right right right
so you could just I see so you just do a
down sample so I mean like in this graph
for example if I did that has 16,000
nodes if I did percent forty one if I
said um sub graph of percent 41 comma
down sample of vertex list
a percent 41 comma let's say 50 times
down sampling is that what how
downsample works
so how down sample works I think to go
look cool quite fine except what an
earth is that blob at the bottom I do
what am i think that exercise should
well but also what is that that that is
a down sampled graph so that's probably
the big central cluster that sort of
I've never seen it do that what a weird
thing
oh you think those are disconnected
components so if you think if I down
solver by a smaller factor I'll see oh I
see okay that's weird and the only the
only issue here is that the size of the
dots has gotten a bit out of control yes
but it's not obviously bad I don't think
that's a bad result um yeah hey
thing I was trying to do I've got two
graphs and I want their vertices to be
the same size so I've got two graphs
they're in the same overall bounding box
you know it's graph a go and graph B and
I want to compare the two of them but I
want their vertices to be the same size
and right now we're having to write a
bunch of hacky code to make that happen
any comments on that Charles that
exercise goes to scale Cody doesn't work
um that's a good question I don't know
why that wouldn't work uh ask max why
that doesn't work I don't know I mean
I'm pretty sure you will have tried that
um okay all right onward here all right
I I as I said I would really like to get
some experience with these annotation
things and I will try to do that in the
next week or so all right
obsolete the graph style symbol alright
fine fine maximum cut
um okay comment from Lucas on the live
stream that down something for graphs
would be the group strongly connected
components try and get four vertices
into single ones oh I see
with all the outgoing edges be preserved
so in other words if you've got like a
an area where it's basically a complete
graph just contract that yeah that's
more or less more excellent I mean if
it's strongly connected within that
component right you know if you suggest
that you don't say that okay
so if I take a complete graph and I say
vertex replace in that and I say table I
goes to one I up to I from six to ten
for example are you saying that it will
do
that's cool okay so that's the beginning
of that process but could you mention
this to max and I I think he could make
a prototype of this okay yes yes I'm
fine
graph two of the maximum number of edges
cut oh that's good
you do here in terms of placing them
correctly there's a ton of layouts
specialized layouts as well as general
once and in particular for the
specialized ones one can find an
algorithmic criteria like these ones if
you look at look at the below what the
new one looks like see oh I see and it's
like that for many of them or wait wait
wait what's the difference it's just
they're a little bit closer no they go
outside they know where the edges goes
are they not printing oh very nice
so if I say random graph this is twelve
one that I'm running right yeah
obviously if I say random graph like 100
200 and then I say vertex labels -
automatic so that one isn't
a general layout supposed to specialize
layout okay and now for this one it
needs to run a different and some kind
of optimization algorithm if it's gonna
find better yeah and do we have any way
to do that right now
yes actually hopefully same idea where I
mean is anything I can run or is it is
it just something that's coming is
something called me I don't remember
exactly what was the option we we didn't
want to document it yet
if there is one could you tell it to max
please and you can play with it okay
those stuff we're doing okay let's
quickly look here you probably don't
really have time to go into this oh my
gosh oh this is mostly documentation
changes that are correct yeah it's
mostly examples but also notes yes okay
so is it is it in the documentation here
so I say prime by nu upon PI lots of
fancy
efforts so how high can I get you cannot
reach the non limit which is 10 to the
30 so that is the current the current
version we don't go be above 10 so why
isn't this is 12 1 so why am i running
the new version what a beaut you haven't
yet emerged okay let me just see that
just for fun so the documentation
changes I'm sure a great uhm is
that's a weird thing that's
so bigger that's produced a problem in
the sauce here whatever's happening in
the 12:1 prototype oh come on did it
just crash well that's what happens when
you're running a prototype build fine I
can't see it so sad oh maybe it didn't
crash who knows okay so okay so prime PI
is new that's wonderful
so what is for how far can Prime go
[Music]
search for efficiency oh I see we know
prime PI but so we can't get prime below
above the 10 to the 30th limit for prime
PI presumably yes so we're doing it as
some kind of binary search or something
on prime PI to find the nth prime okay
and is it do we have fine
state-of-the-art algorithms for these
things now yes multi-threaded that's
cool huh okay okay and I think
particularly to look at it and I'd love
to look at these in more detail but is
there nothing particularly to see here
okay great all right I think that's
probably everything for for right now um
I really look forward to playing around
some more with this graph stuff and
kind of checking checking the story I'm
still a little worried about the
annotation stuff although I think it's
gonna be okay
all right anything else here okay
thanks thanks to folks a live stream had
some good suggestions thank you for
things like Sanders vertex last
suggestion
very good much appreciated alright see
you soon